Se ido. Mhm.
que quiero ver ir a
a esto de la asignatura,
¿vale? Luego vamos a ver tema el tema de
tarjetas de red y empezamos ya con redes
IP y todo eso que que creo que va a
estar más interesante que en el temario,
¿vale? Es que yo lo que quiero ver
es de la asignatura esta,
¿vale? tenemos que la evaluación, esto
lo hemos visto antes, que la evaluación
de esta asignatura es
el 70%
corresponderá examen
y el 30% actividades que vayamos
realizando. Entonces, a lo mejor la
diferencia
en
o si vais muy raspadillos con el examen,
las actividades que vayáis haciendo os
van a os van a ir bien o a la hora de
participar en clase, no sé, también es
que es
todo hace. Vale,
vale. No, lo que yo quería ver era
exactamente
el tema de
los
Vale,
a ver, tenemos las tarjetas de red.
Vamos a descargarlas.
Guardar.
Vale. Y la abrimos
y tenemos aquí las tarjetas de red.
Vale.
Y ya después de esto sí que nos ponemos
ya con las redes IPv4.
Eso va a estar más más chulo, más
interesante.
Pero dejadme que vea una cosa.
Segundito. Versión
y
la uno sería redes locales
y en redes locales tenemos
como medios de transmisión.
H
que no quiero incidir mucho en lo de las
señales tampoco porque no es algo que,
o sea, está bien, está bien como
temario, pero tampoco es lo fundamental
eh
del del este interconexión de equipos
entreras locales.
Vale, vamos a ver lo de las tarjetas de
red.
Realmente es que es que lo de las
señales, ya te digo yo que no me
que lo he visto así un poco raro, ¿eh?
Le echaré un le echaré un vistazo. Bien
a eso. Y si eso oye, si hay que incidir
ahí se incide.
Vale, venga, tarjetas de red. Vale, una
tarjeta de red también llamada placa de
red
o network interface car. Una nick es una
clase de tarjeta destinada a ser
introducida
en la placa base de un ordenador.
Realmente
eh muchos muchas placas bases vienen ya
integradas con su propia tarjeta de red.
En la mayoría de los casos hoy en día, a
no ser de que creamos algo muy especial,
que una tarjeta de red que admita más
velocidad, que sea que sea más fluida,
etcétera, etcétera, o que tenga incluso
o o necesitamos necesitamos hacer un un
ordenador normal que sea que sea nuestro
servidor, hombre, no es lo ideal, ¿vale?
Imaginad que tenemos que tener ese
ordenador conectado a internet y a la
vez a una LAN,
¿vale? Entonces, en es en esos casos sí
que sí que insertaríamos una tarjeta de
red. ¿Dónde la pincharíamos? Pues,
hombre, generalmente iría al puerto PCI,
PCI Express.
Antiguamente iba a otro tipo de puertos,
no sé, ha ido cambiando, o sea, desde
los puertos ISO hasta los puertos,
pasando luego por los puertos PCI y hoy
en día puertos PCI Express
y en un futuro será otra cosa,
¿vale? también en muchos en muchos
en muchos ordenadores, en portátiles, lo
que sí que lo que sí que había. Ahora ya
no lo hay. Vale, si venían con una
tarjeta de expansión. Esto de aquí, esto
de la pelea esta,
esto sería una tarjeta de expansión, por
ejemplo, para metern.
Si te fijas, ahí tiene una serie de de
un puerto, ¿vale? ¿Dónde se que se
llamará X? O sea, no sé cómo se llamará
este puerto de la PDA,
pero ahí sí que podemos integrar TRL,
cualquier otro
servicio. Bueno,
vale. En la placa en la placa va a ser
una computadora se conecta en uno de sus
puertos para posibilitar que la máquina
se sume una red y pueda compartir sus
recursos con documentos, conexión
internet, impresora, etcétera. Existen
diversos tipos de tarjeta de red, placas
o adaptadores de red en función del tipo
de cableado o arquitectura en la red.
Por ejemplo, están los adaptadores de
redacción alámbrica, los adaptadores
wifi, que bien puede ser puede ser
interno pinchado en la placa, puede ser
un un USB,
puede ser una tarjeta de expansión de
esas, es que eso está en desuso
realmente.
Vale. Adaptador de red USB. Se conecte a
un puerto USB estándar para habilitar
las conexiones de red de la computadora,
generalmente wifi o eternet.
Puede ser también un adaptador de juegos
inalámbricos, es decir, llamado
adaptador de medios.
Pues se cons se conecta una consola,
juegos, Xbox, PlayStation u otro
producto de entretenimiento en el hogar.
Proporción un puente a la capacidad
inalámbrica wifi
adaptador PCI.
A menudo llamado NIC era un tipo de
tarjeta adicional instalada dentro de
una computadora personal de escritorio o
tarjeta de PC,
también conocido como tarjetas PC macía
insertado en el costado de una
computadora portátil para proporcionar
estos serían las tarjetas esas de que os
digo para mira una tarjeta si es que
tengo en casa.
A ver,
G,
no, que esto ya pues nada, está
todo jurásico ya todo,
pero igual estáis en una tienda
reparando PCs o cualquier cosa y os
llegan cosas de estas.
Vale, esto sería una tarjeta
a ver,
mirad, aquí lo tenéis. Vale, esto se
insertaba
en la en el puerto que se me hacía y
tenías pues ampliabas con dos USBs o
puerto de serie
o tarjeta de red.
Bluetooth también algunos casos. Lector
de lector de tarjetas
de tarjetas de de
tarjetas de memoria. ¿Sabéis que
tarjetas de memoria no están solo las
mini micro SDS? O sea, que es hay
factores de forma unos cuantos.
Vale. Y aquí tenéis el puerto,
el portátil con el A ver. Sí,
a ver si sale así.
Vale, no no se ve, no se ve el puerto
del portátil, pero vamos, más o menos
una ranura, una ranura así eh
rectangular bastante alargada
donde introducido el la tarjeta esta.
Esta es de audio, esta es una son
blaster.
está en concreto.
Vale, hoy en día hay soluciones USB para
todo esto. O sea, imaginad que os viene
un cliente con el con el que no le
funciona el audio y no hay manera porque
el jack se ha
se ha desintegrado dentro del dentro del
ordenador por lo que sea o el chiquillo
le ha metido plastilina y no hay manera
de sacarlo. A ver, pues una solución
interesante es ponerle un una tarjeta
externa
mediante USB, ¿no? Obviamente esto no
porque no tendréis puerto de de PC
Pencía. O sea, no creo que os venga
ningún cliente con con un ordenador de
o pues sí, no sé.
Bueno,
vale. El adaptador PCI a menuda llamado
Nick era un tipo de tarjeta adicional
instalada dentro de una computadora
personal de escritorio, tarjeta PC,
también conocido como tarjetas PC,
insertado en el costado de una
computadora portátil para proporcionar
una capacidad similar.
Conector RJ45 de cable óptico para
tarjetas de fibra óptica.
Vale, adaptadores de red virtual.
Ciertos tipos de adaptadores de red no
tienen componentes de hardware, sino que
consisten únicamente en software. Estos
a menudo se dominan actores virtuales en
contraste con un adaptador físico.
Vale, hablamos de de Virtual Box,
¿vale? Cualquier tipo de tarjeta de red
cumple con ocho funciones básicas.
Transmisión y recepción de datos. Acer
al conector que a su vez acceder al
cable de red, llevar a cabo la
conversión de sería paralelo.
Buofering, que sería almacenar la
información para que luego se pueda
transmitir
los datos por el cable sistemas
inalámbricos.
Petición de escuchar la red para luego
transmitir la información. codifica y
decodifica las señales de los cables en
nota reconocibles por los terminales o
la red o agrupa el conjunto de datos
almacenados para que se puedan
transportar de una manera entendible y
comunicar los datos con la memoria del
ordenador.
La velocidad de transmisión varía según
el tipo de placa de red. Las últimas
pueden soportar más velocidad de montera
hasta 10,000 por segundo.
¿Vale? Aquí tenéis las velocidades.
Pues eso cuando entramos en en
PC componentes, por ejemplo, cualquiera
de estas, podemos ver, o sea, a la hora
de configurar un
ordenador o imaginar que os pide el
encargo en segundo.
Yo no sé si en primero hicisteis algún
proyecto así intermodular o algo de eso,
algo hicisteis ya al final. Si al final
no
vale, no es que en segundo sí que se
utiliza esto, ¿vale? Entonces sí que
tienes que que hacer un catálogo del de
qué cosas vas a emplear,
¿vale? Como un presupuesto.
Creo que lo que hicimos fue como montar
un como una tienda, un sitio había que
con presupuesto, cables,
¿vale? Vale, entonces ibais buscando
componentes, ¿no? A ver cuál
cuál era el que más encajaba dependiendo
de las de las necesidades.
Vale,
por eso os digo que cuando estamos
buscando un un dispositivo, por ejemplo,
vamos al PC componentes este o el PC
Box.
Bueno, PC componentes, va
componentes
y nos vamos a buscar tarjetas de red.
A ver qué tipo de
filtrado
nos deja.
Por buscar algunas
que tengan velocidad,
una velocidad alta de transmisión.
está posiblemente.
Vale, si le vemos las caras, claro, el
precio también nos lo está diciendo,
¿no? Son 487 € la tarjetita.
Se iría conectada al puerto PCI Express.
Y bueno, pues tenemos ahí todas las
velocidades que nos admite cuando lo
normal,
o sea, da cuenta, eh,
cuando lo normal es que
pues vamos a una
así de hogar, pues yo que sé, esta,
hombre, 126 ya va bien, ¿eh?
Esta,
por ejemplo, no sé, esta está en
promoción. Son 10 Gabit.
R
chusquerilla.
Está claro, esto es muy baratono. sería
USB
y transmite velocidad, pues eso, o sea,
en consonancia también con el que no
está mal, o sea, para una red del hogar
si es que no te va a ir mal tampoco.
Esta, por ejemplo, a ver qué velocidades
te da.
Esta no es mala marca.
Y esta es de,
¿vale? Aquí tenemos la las velocidades
de transferencia comparado con aquella
que nos va a cubrir unas necesidades
específicas, pues claro, de un salto
bastante bastante importante en
velocidades.
Me quedo con curiosidad de esta. Bueno,
10, 100 y 1000.
No, estas no se ven. No, pero es que
claro, es que esta es
esta se va ya bastante. Esta es la que
hemos estado viendo antes.
Os cuenta.
Vale, esto es lo que quería ver.
las velocidades que te alcanza que te
alcanza una. Bueno, en base lo hemos
visto ahí, pero aquí lo vemos mejor,
¿vale?
más traducido
y pues eso, tenemos
esta que nos alcanza velocidades
10, 100, 1000,
mientras que esta
se nos va a todo esto.
Lo dicho, depende de siempre de lo que
vayamos a necesitar. Tenemos que adaptar
una una solución a otra. Sí.
tenemos unas necesidades más altas, pues
obviamente siempre el presupuesto va a
ser más alto.
Vale, esto no era.
Estamos
cerrados aquí.
Yo creo ceros
llegado al final. Vale, actualmente
pues eso ya haremos catálogos de Vamos a
redescp
Vale.
O sea,
yo digo,
ya está. Lo guardamos.
¿Dónde?
Vale, tenemos
estamos en esta
y tenemos las redes.
Vale,
descargamos.
Ok.
Vale, vamos vamos a ver el tema de
de dirección IP.
Vale,
imagina que quieres enviarle una carta o
un paquete a un a un amigo. ¿Qué es lo
primero
que necesitas?
La dirección postal,
¿vale? El nombre, la calle, el número,
la ciudad, el código postal. Si en esa
dirección la carta del paquete se
perdería y nunca llegaría a sus manos.
Pues en el mundo de las redes donde
miles de millones de dispositivos,
ordenadores, móviles, tablet, PDA,
alguna PDA que otra,
el bueno, consolas, no sé, o sea,
neveras, hoy en día las neveras,
aparatos de aire acondicionado, si es
que, o sea, cualquier dispositivo
conectado a la red,
¿vale? Pues pues eso, o sea, todos
necesitan su su número de teléfono, que
sería su dirección IP,
¿vale? Y esto es un jaleo y entonces lo
que vamos a estudiar es cómo se regula
todo esto,
¿vale? para que un mensaje de WhatsApp,
un vídeo de YouTube o una partida online
lleguen a tu dispositivo y no al de tu
vecino. Cada uno de estos aparatos
conectados necesita su propia dirección
única, su domicilio digital.
Vale, no es más que h, a ver, hay dos,
digamos que hay dos protocolos, está el
antiguo, el que se ha venido usando
hasta ahora mayoritariamente, que sería
el IPV4, sería el protocolo de internet
versión 4 y luego tenemos el el IPV6.
Nosotros nos vamos a centrar ahora en el
cuatro. El cuatro sería eh, o sea,
bueno, os explico, es el sistema de
dirección más usado del mundo
actualmente y el que ha permitido que
internet crezca hasta lo que es hoy.
¿Alguna vez habréis visto una dirección
IP, no? 92 168
un 1, o sea, 1.1, o sea, unas una serie
de cifras separadas por por puntitos,
por puntos, perdón, más que por
puntitos, que eso estaríamos hablando ya
de de las IPV6,
¿vale? Pues pues eso sería la dirección
IP, ¿no? Eh, ¿cuántas direcciones IP hay
en el mundo? Por ejemplo, ¿sabéis
cuántas
cuántas hay?
Infinitas, ¿no? Supongo,
¿no? Que va, no, no, para nada.
infinitas. O sea, así la respuesta corta
son
4,96
7,296
direcciones IP cuatro únicas en el
mundo. Lo que pasa que tiene truco
porque claro, o sea, tú puedes tener,
que ahora lo veremos, tú puedes tener la
Y tú, ¿cuál tenías antes que lo hemos
estado mirando? la 1 147
posible posiblemente 15,000 tíos tienen
la misma que tú en su casa. Lo que pasa
que está son serían redes privadas.
Entonces claro, ahí está un poquito el
juego de lo que es una red pública y una
red privada,
¿vale? O sea, sí que en las redes
privadas sí que habría réplica en la
numeración de las IPs, pero
pertenecerían a una red a dentro de una
red pública, digamos que que sería algo
así como
mm como la misma. Imagínate que, vale,
sí, esto sería un buen ejemplo, que hay
dos pueblos diferentes,
cinco pueblos que tienen la misma calle
mayor número 37, puerta 4, pero son
pueblos diferentes, ¿vale? Entonces, esa
sería tu IP 19216817,
porque en el pueblo de de al lado
también tendrían esa esa IP
o vivirían en esa calle mayor, número
67, tal,
¿vale?
Una dirección IPV4 se escribe con cuatro
números separados por puntos.
Voy a sacar la piezca.
a pasear.
Aquí se puede
pezar por aquí.
Ah.
no es
es que eso no sería
saco el otro el
que me mola más.
Vale,
que lo tengo por aquí.
Vale, una dirección IP se escribe con
cuatro números separados por puntos. Por
ejemplo,
la 192
pun
168.
1.1,
¿vale? Pero en realidad para la red es
un número binario de 32 bits. Cada uno
de los números de los cada uno de los
cuatro números puede ir del 0 al 255.
O sea, aquí teníamos
eh 255.
Aquí teníamos 255.
Aquí teníamos 250. En la posición, me
refiero, eh, no me refiero que esto
signifique 20 255.
¿Por qué? Porque tendríamos
un bit, otro bit, otro bit,
otro bit. O sea, serían una sucesión de
8 bits, serían cuatro tetos.
Espera, y
4 37, ¿no?
De tal manera que sería 1 2 4 8 16 32
64 y 128. La suma de todo esto nos da
los 255.
Vale, y esto lo tendríamos repetido en
por cuatro veces. Al final nos da 8 * 4
32. La suma total,
la suma total de todas estas cantidades
nos da 32.
Nos da 32 bits. ¿Vale?
Vale, queda claro esto de dónde.
Vale,
vale. Para calcular el total de
combinaciones posibles, calculamos 2
elevado 32, porque cada bit puede ser 0
o 1. Entonces, ¿de dónde salían los 4200
millones de de direcciones IP? Después
de calcular los dos elevado a 32,
entonces todas esas dos. Dime. Contacto
esta mañana con tus alumnos hermanos.
Sí, sí, lo he visto. Sí.
A ver si
escuchan que hagamos ejercicio.
Si ya lo he dicho yo 20 veces. Lo he
dicho intima, es que distancia es muy
importante
ya hombre es que date cuenta
es que no estoy recalcando
pero
lo sé
más bien.
Sí, tenemos que hablar de lo del
Sí, de la aplicación ahora luego lo
miro.
Es que sí, sí, no sé, no sé qué puede
pasar. Reviso tu correo porque estoy con
varias cosas a la vez. Yo también estoy
intentando ver cómo consigo para que
luego sustien
muy al día el porcentaje de asistencia
por si se pierden el derecho a
evaluación por asignatura, por ejemplo,
bueno, tiene que son tan poquitas horas
en una evaluación que falte cinco
clases, cinco ya estás rozando el límite
lo que te verdad
eh
que sí que sí no no es que yo he
calculado que bueno quiero la semana de
antes que le diga mira como ha faltado
seis veces pasa estás un 70% y yo no
podré evaluarte.
A mí lo que me lo que me gusta, o sea,
yo estuve sacando para el módulo de de
segundo
proyecto intermodular estoy sacando o
sea que hace é oito y lo tengo ya
bastante redactado. Vale,
eso porque vosotros eso lo paséis a
hostellerería.
Eso es una didática. Esto también es una
pero no tienes que presentarla. Lo
tenemos que tener.
Tenemos que tenerlo. Sería interesante.
Pues si lo vas teniendo teniendolo
yo tengo el global, pero no lo que voy
haciendo es por fases para que vayan
entregando fases. Ahora en una primera
fase lo que van a hacer es entregar el
cómo se dice el o sea comemos estato. O
sea, somos un grupo de tres y no sé cada
uno sino una cada uno sin esto. Eso es
esto, esto, esto.
Claro, como todavía temario no tenemos
realmente. Es que al principio hay un
poco de proyectar.
Es lo que les dije a los de la mañana
porque como te quitan horas de red horas
de otras tú noas
a verdades no en este caso sería en
segundo
y a lo mejor en primeras semanas no dar
no a lo mejor intentar reforzar ese
contenido que por la falta de horas tú
no te das tiempo año. Sí.
Tú de vez en cuando alterno,
chora que viene la hora del proyecto
vamos a trabajar esto de esta asignatura
porque como se han trabajado las ras
y que y que además está relacionada.
Claro, al final eso no sol para el
proyecto.
Claro, es que al final es eso, o sea,
pero yo entiendo que primeras tres
semanas hasta noviembre.
Es que este mes, yo no el primer día
además fue el primer día que me tocó la
está bien. Exacto.
Entonces es que dije mi fij fue así. Es
que claro, o sea, yo dije que es verdad
que con vosotros no hablé porque como
habríais la razón todos nosotros y a lo
mejor se haban.
Pues mira, de eso no habíamos hablado ya
bajado es que se me quejaron. es
que tú abras de aquí y no recortante tem
Mario y ahora voy a ir super justo para
hacer lo mismo. recortar pues mira antes
de recortar aprovecha la primera semana
del curso que hacer
no no puedes hacer nada si es que yo
luego ya con
ejemplo o yo te digo que te duermes este
febrero a mejor septiembre y octubre
pues ya puede ser adelantar horas de 500
para que luego te dé tiempo a
sí
o contenidos que a mí no me va a
dar tiempo porque me han quitado 30
horas cojo y dedico esta semana aquella
y aquella refuerzo y la uso para final
lo voy a hacer así que si no que
es que si no habrá que recortar cosas
que no
claro porque es que tampoco me interesa
tanto que vale que sí que hagamos sus
estatutos internos y tal pero tampoco
voy a incidir la eso está un par de
semanas mira vamos a aprovechar las
siguientes semanas en esto así
reforzamos los conceptos de est
pues si instalaremos algo de WordPress o
algo Sí, ya por lo menos que vayan
punteando
para
ver por dónde iba. Disculpar. ¡Uf! Vale,
estábamos hablando de eso, o sea, si
alguno quiere calcular el 2 elevado a
32, pues nos daría eso.
Es serían los cuatro grupos de ocho de 8
bits.
Vale, esto no. Vamos a ponerlo aquí.
serían un total de
y aquí no me lo va a dejar poner ya más
No,
e acciones. Qué mal escribo con esto,
¿eh?
Es que hasta que se acostumbra, ¿no?
Vale, pues eso sería, o sea, eso no es
una dirección IP, sería el número
número
eh
número posible de
número Exacto.
Número de direcciones y P. Vale, vale,
continuamos.
Vale, pero nos hemos quedado sin
direcciones, ¿no? Porque lo que os he
explicado antes creo que es buen
ejemplo. O sea, vives en pueblos
diferentes, pero en la misma calle
mayor, porque todos esos pueblos tienen
la calle, su calle mayor, número 67,
segundo piso, eh, puerta tres.
Vale, pero no es la dirección. ¿Por qué?
porque falla dirección de del pueblo. O
sea, uno es uno es Nubles y el otro es
Villamarchante y el otro es veteran.
Vale,
vale. En el mundo, pues eso, hay más de
8000 millones de personas y miles de
millones de dispositivos. O sea, es que
se nos quedaría cortísimo esa cifra de
de 4294
millones de direcciones.
¿Vale? ¿Cómo es posible que internet
siga funcionando entonces? Pues aquí
entrarán en juego soluciones ingeniosas
que estiran las direcciones posibles.
Vale, tendríamos las direcciones
direcciones privadas,
¿vale? que sería la solución del del
portal Zawan, o sea, lo que hemos dicho,
calle mayor número 67, se reservan unos
rangos de direcciones como
pues yo que sé, la 9 192.168
10 172. Luego aquí en los apuntes, a
ver,
espera, voy a minimizar esto.
Bueno, aquí si tenéis la diferencia
entre entre IPv4, IPV6,
eh, la diferencia principal es el
tamaño.
IPV son 32 bits. Ahora calcularemos
cuántos son los 128 bits de IPV6, que
eso sí que da una burrada. Lo tengo por
aquí.
Tengo una comparativa por Sí, mira, lo
tengo aquí. Os digo,
¿vale? El router en la red direcciones
privadas, ¿vale? la port la solución
para para solucionar todo esto. El
router crea una red interna y asigna tu
móvil, portátil, nevera, aire
acondicionado,
eh tablet,
no sé, el dispositivo que quieras,
¿vale? y le y le asigna una dirección IP
h ya sea de modo
de modo dinámico. Bueno, eso ya
entraremos que eso ya forma parte de de
otro de otras unidades,
¿vale? Para el mundo exterior todos
vuestros dispositivos comparten una una
única dirección IP
que es una única dirección IP pública,
¿vale? Y esta nos la proporciona el
proveedor de internet al que tenemos al
que tenemos con el que tenemos el
contrato, ya sea Digi, Movistar,
Vodafone, a su vez a Digi me imagino que
le que le asignador alguna
los señores de Movestar no lo sé, o sea,
eso ya desconozco,
¿vale? Pero esto, pero, pero es,
o sea, nuestra puerta con el mundo es
sería el nombre del pueblo, que este
nombre del pueblo ya nos lo proporciona
el ISP que tengamos, que sería el
operador de red que nos que nos asigna
la IP, ¿no? No tendría nada que ver con
la dirección que nos asigna el router,
¿vale? El router hace de portero o
traductor usando la usando NAT network
address translection recordando a quién
debe entregar la respuesta cuando llegue
información de internet,
¿vale? algo así como si en un edificio
de apartamentos
tu red local
todos compartían la misma dirección
postal, la IP pública, pero luego el
portero, que sería el router, se encarga
de llevar la carta al a la puerta
correcta,
¿vale? En este caso, tu móvil, tu
ordenador,
eso sería, ¿vale? El sucesor IPV6.
La sucesión a largo plazo es IPV IPv6. O
sea, lo habréis visto alguna Espera que
os lo pongo.
Me imagino lo habréis visto alguna vez.
IP
V 6.
Eso si hacemos en
si hacemos un IP config,
veremos que a ver, sería en la wifi,
esta sería
la dirección IP V4 de asignada aquí en
el en en el instituto y la IPV6 sería
esta de aquí que está escrita en códigos
a decimal.
Vale. Eh,
vale. Aquí tendríamos la puerta de la
puerta, ¿vale? Sí, la puerta de enlace.
Esta sería la comunicación con nuestro
router, con el router de aquí, sería
sería esta de aquí, ¿vale? Y luego aquí
tendríamos la marca la máscara de subred
que ahora veremos también el tema de las
máscaras de su red, ¿vale? Número de
direcciones IPV6, ¿alguien lo ha
calculado en este en este ratillo que
estamos aquí hablando?
No, pues un huevazo porque sería
serían
dos,
o sea, esto sería IPV4
y esto sería IPV6, que serían 2 elevado
a 128.
O sea, aquí ya nos salen unas cuantas
que básicamente
nos salen
que no sé decir la cifra realmente.
Os la pego
porque es muy larga de escribir.
Esto.
Son no sé cuántos trillones de no sé
qué. O sea, había una comparación
por ahí.
Mira, son
vienen a ser miles de millones de
direcciones IP por cada milímetro
cuadrado de la superficie terrestre.
O sea, imagínate
la magnitud de la que estamos hablando.
Vale, 340 estillones.
Casi no
en dinero estaría bien eso
y querríamos más
que eso no se conforma uno nunca.
Vale. Eh,
aunque es un el realmente las CPV4,
aunque sea un número limitado, pues pues
hasta ahora están funcionando, ¿vale? Y
sí que,
pero el futuro sin duda sería pues eso,
pasarse al sistema. Este es más algo más
complejo de de calcular a nivel de de
humano, pero
aquí lo pongo. 340.
Casi nada.
Bueno, casi 340, ¿no? Madre mía.
Bueno, venga.
Vale. Eh, ¿qué es una dirección IPv4?
Bueno, pues una dirección IPv4 es un
identificador único y lógico asignado un
dispositivo host en una red que utiliza
el protocolo IPV o perdón IP es como el
DNI de tu equipo en la red.
Lo hemos hablado antes, características
tiene 32 bits
para eh son 32 unos y ceros,
¿vale? Y para que sea más fácil de leer
de leer y recordar los números para los
humanos, dividimos esos 32 bit en cuatro
grupos de ocho llamados obtetos, lo que
hemos estado viendo antes, y los
convertimos a decimal. Cada obteto puede
ir de 0 a 255
y vamos a convertir, por ejemplo, el
el 192.
Me voy a separar porque si no luego 168
pun 1.1.
Aquí ya sabemos que son
estamos hablando de longitud, eh, no de
valores,
no de valores numéricos. O sea, aquí sí
que debemos de presentar de representar
todos los ceros que aparecen
antes del antes del uno.
Sería esto.
Este sería este, el 168 sería,
vamos a hacerlo, vamos a recordarlo aquí
sería, eh,
1 2 4 8 16
32 64
y 128.
Vale, pues tendríamos aquí en el 128
pondríamos uno. 128 y 64 ya se nos
escapa. Se nos va a más de se nos va a
180 192, ¿no? Entonces aquí pondríamos
un cero,
¿vale? 128 y 32 serían 150
y 160.
160.
Aquí pondríamos uno, ¿vale? El 16 pues
ya se nos escapa también. Aquí
pondríamos un cero, aquí pondríamos un 1
y tendríamos el 168 justo. Entonces ya
este cuatro, este do y este uno ya no
los necesitaríamos y poníamos
esos ceros, ¿vale? Entonces tenemos que
sería 1
0 1 0, mira, aquí me ha cabido bien.
Cero. Vale, tenemos otro obteto.
Y por último el 192, que este la verdad
es que me lo sebe porque son el 128 + 64
son 192,
son 192. Entonces, lo único que tenemos
que poner son seis ceros detrás.
Y ese sería la traducción de el número
el número IP a binario. Y os recuerdo
eso. O sea, aquí no quitéis los ceros
porque son estamos hablando de
longitudes y no de valores
numéricos,
¿vale? Eh, más cosillas,
¿vale? Partes de una dirección IP red y
host. Vale, vale. Hemos visto que una
dirección IP es es como un domicilio,
pero ahora vamos a destriparla para
entender su anatomía.
Uno de los conceptos, este es uno de los
conceptos más importantes y
fundamentales en las redes porque es la
base para que los datos sepan cómo
viajar. toda. Habíamos hablado antes de
pueblos, calles mayores y todo eso. Pues
aquí es donde encontramos la traducción
a
a las direcciones IP. Toda dirección IP
tiene dos partes bien diferenciadas, la
parte de red y la parte de host. La
parte de red
eh network, que sería la ciudad o el
código postal, ¿vale? aquello del del
pueblo o el código postal o el barrio,
¿vale? Es la parte de la dirección que
identifica de forma única la red
completa a la que pertenece el
dispositivo.
En analogía postal sería el equivalente
al nombre de la ciudad y el código
postal, por ejemplo, 46018 de Valencia.
Todos los que vivan en esa zona
compartirán este mismo código postal.
Vale, por lo tanto aquí,
vale, espera, vamos a poner una una
diferenciación.
Vale.
¿Y para qué sirve todo esto? Pues los
routers
solo miran esta parte para tomar
decisiones cruciales. Su trabajo es
preguntarle, ¿está el destino en mi
misma red o en una remota?
Si la parte de red es la misma, los
dispositivos están en la misma red y
pueden comunicarse directamente. Si es
diferente, el route enviará el paquete
hacia otra red, normalmente hacia
internet.
Y la parte de host sería la calle,
la calle y el número,
¿vale? Es la parte de la dirección que
identifica de forma única a un
dispositivo específico dentro de su
propia red local. O sea, como digamos el
número el piso y el número de puerta,
¿vale? Ya dentro de la bueno, el la
calle, esto sería la calle mayor número
67, puerta puerta tres.
¿Vale? ¿Y para qué sirve? Pues una vez
que el paquete de datos ha llegado a la
red correcta, gracias a la parte a la
parte de red, el switch o el punto de
acceso wifi de esa red, el switch o el
punto de acceso wifi de esa red utiliza
la parte de host para enterar los datos
al dispositivo exacto que los está
esperando tu móvil, ordenador
o o y no al de al de un vecino o al de
tu hermano,
¿vale? Vale, entonces esto sería,
tenemos un ejemplo, tendríamos la
punto. Vamos con las 192, ¿vale? Porque
son fáciles. 1 50, ¿vale? Esta es la
red,
una red asignada a tu a tu ordenador en
tu casa.
Vale, ¿cuál sería la parte de red y cuál
sería la parte de la parte de host?
¿Sabéis?
Vale, pues la parte de red,
perdón,
la parte de red sería el 192
168. punto uno y la parte de host es
este, que es el que identifica a tu
dispositivo
dentro de esa red.
Esto sería la red y esto el host.
¿Por qué lo sabemos? Pues por la
por lo lo sabremos por lo siguiente, que
sería lo siguiente que vamos a hablar es
de las máscaras de red.
Vale, otros dispositivos de tu de tu
casa podrían ser pues h
podrían ser podrían acabar en
es que depende depende del router,
depende de cómo lo tengamos configurado.
Podría ser la 51 el siguiente que se ha
conectado. Es que depende como la
tengamos conectado. Podemos incluso
establecer un rango de la 100 a la 150,
de la dos a la a la 254.
¿Vale? Entonces el router nos irá
asignando a los diferentes dispositivos.
Imaginar que sois 60 personas en casa.
Hombre, no es lo habitual,
pero imaginar eso, 60 personas con tres
dispositivos cada uno, pues ya ahí las
direcciones IPs, la verdad es que se, o
sea, en 60 personas a lo mejor tiene que
haber un tiene que haber impresoras y
tiene que haber, o sea, que los 200 las
25 direcciones se quedarían cortas
posiblemente.
¿Vale? Entonces ahí tendremos que
configurar el router de otra manera,
¿vale? Vale. Que tienen como un to, esto
significa que todos pertenecen a la
misma famil.168.1.51
52 53
etcétera.
¿Vale?
Todos pertenecen a la misma familia o
red local. Cuando tu consola le pide un
vídeo a YouTube, el router de tu casa,
ve que la dirección de YouTube
8.8.8.8,
por ejemplo, tiene una parte de red
completamente diferente. Entonces dice,
"Este paquete no es para mi red."
¿Vale? En cambio, cuando quieres
imprimir un documento, tu ordenador,
pongamos por caso el 1.50
192168 150,
enviar los datos a la impresora que a lo
pongamos por caso que es la 51 192 168
151.
El router ve ambas direcciones, ve que
ambas direcciones comparten la misma
parte de red que sería el 192168.1
un y permite que se comuniquen
directamente dentro de la red de casa de
forma rápida, eficiente, sin necesidad
de salir a internet.
¿Vale? ¿Y cómo cómo sé dónde termina la
red y dónde empieza el host?
Vale, pues aquí entraría en juego el
concepto de máscara de red. La máscara
de red es como una plantilla que se
superpone la dirección IP y nos dice qué
parte es red y qué parte es host. Una
máscara típica para una red doméstica
sería
la
255.255.255
pun0.
Donde hay, o sea, donde pone 255.
La máscara nos indica que es la parte de
red. ¿Veis en este cuál sería la máscara
de red de este
de este, por ejemplo, del 19218
150?
La máscara de red es esta, ¿no? No hemos
llegado realmente hasta ahí, ¿vale?
Porque sí que tenemos que ver un poco
las tablas de hasta dónde llegan los
tipos de direcciones IP que están
clasificados en varias en varias
categorías dependiendo de de cómo
comienzan
y cómo terminan. ¿Vale? Entonces ahora
llegamos ahí su más la máscara de red de
esta de esta dirección IP sería esta.
¿Vale? Entonces, a ver.
La máscara de red
de este
sería esta de aquí.
Vale,
vale. ¿Alguna pregunta hasta aquí?
Vale, si queréis lo dejamos aquí.
Continuamos mañana con máscaras de red y
os os he pasado ejercicio de aquí de
estas o no. No, vale, pues mañana lo
hacemos.
Vale, pues mañana lo hacemos.
Mañana la clase lo hacemos y ya está.
Pues dejar un ratillo para que lo veáis
y luego lo vamos contestando.
Vale. Eh, bueno, lo que hemos hablado
antes de ejercicios, los que no habéis
hecho, los que no habéis entregado
ejercicios de esta asignatura, lo que
voy a hacer es os amplío el plazo,
pero no vais a sacar tanta puntuación si
si acertáis de pleno todas.
Vamos a hacerlo. Que merece la pena,
hombre.
¿Qué
has hecho con la PDA? Te la vendo.
Hasta luego.
Venga, hasta luego.
A ver.
un poco.
A mí me suena mucho a
los dispositivos que tenían los policías
para poner multas. No sé si ahora
es que posiblemente
antiguamente